everyone knows who gary v is gary
vaynerchuk yeah
uh
he's been boy
um
he's probably the biggest
influencer out there business influencer
well apparently he's getting divorced
okay is he or did he i well you're gonna
take a look at these pictures and you're
gonna be very you're gonna be yeah i
mean you're it's they use the word
allegedly but when you start posting
pictures of your new girlfriend pretty
much bravo gary how old is he again
is he
how old is he tyler how old is gary i'm
i'm willing to bet that he's in his late
40s that's my guess 47 46. i'd say 48.
i'm guessing
46. 46. okay 46 but he looks like he's
48. here we go so gary is worth between
160 and 200 million which may or may not
be cut in half in the coming months
right that's how we get rich sorry oh
there it was ladies and gentlemen people
want to know
people want to say adam but this is a
financial show why do you always want to
talk about relationships and dating
together it all goes together thank you
tori yeah um you were saying sorry so
basically he's been famously very
private with his wife he never post
pictures of his wife ever never post
pictures of his kids ever
next thing you know boom
this is the pictures that he's dropping
tyler can we put this into the damn so
he's with this new girl called him down
though i believe so he's married his
wife lizzy in 2004 they have two kids
together
is lizzy getting half now this is his
new lady friend girlfriend monavand so
ladies and gentlemen thoughts on garyvee
thoughts on what's happening here and
then i'll open it up for discussion
oh i'm gonna let the ladies go first on
this because this is gonna be good
i think
garyvee is literally the representation
of this microwave society of this hustle
culture be positive just [ __ ] work
just do it and all this [ __ ] so
she's beautiful looking at her like it's
fine but gary vee just fake really fake
fake yeah really
why fake just because
it's this if you really watch his
contact he contradicts himself every
time
that's what i took from it but it's this
constant hustle and i'm like do you even
see your kids
just curious well you might only see
them half the time now do you have um
that's it he's lucky that's if he's
lucky i don't think there's any proof to
show that he spent time with those kids
oh damn well there's no pictures online
let me ask brody
brody if he's if he if he's not
gary vee
if he's not worth 168 on 200 million 160
to 200 does he give with that girl with
that girl that choice oh and i also
think um i think it's really sad to see
this because it kind of reflects the
fear that a lot of women have is that
once we have your babies
in our body for you we do everything for
you and then you just kind of leave us
for a younger woman yeah
is that a woman's biggest fear
yeah is that he married her in 2004
absolutely when he was jack [ __ ] he was
basically selling wine in a seller
and he starts doing stuff online
now he's worth a couple hundred millions
to get it out and now he's he's dating
this young man on the bright side his
his ex-wife and i now has 80 million
dollars so i mean i would take it
you could date whoever you want if i
like you guys go do wine parties with
mckenzie
watching men she's the richest woman in
the world because of japanese watching
famous rich alpha men
never post pictures of their kids never
talk about their families and then post
this are you kidding me i i don't mind
if there's no kids on the social media
that bothers me it freaks me out when
people put their kids on do you post
pictures of your boy the past boyfriends
have you ever post pictures of your
passport
only of my first boyfriend but no none
of the guys you're involved with now but
i'll explain why let me explain why it
actually doesn't have to do a lot with
um i don't know your i actually don't
know where you're going with this but
i'll tell you where it comes from my
family's very religious it's really
awkward for me to be open about my
dating life and my sex life
orthodox that makes sense uh modern
orthodox okay yeah there's a mod so all
of my siblings by the yeah all of my
siblings by the way uh got married
without everybody is rushing to your
instagram right now you realize that
right
they've never touched their partner
before they got married their first kiss
in some cases was on their wedding day
they met through a matchmaker and they
all have relatively healthy marriages
like really beautiful healthy marriages
so do my parents yeah and like there's
something to be said about that well let
me ask you guys a question then because
gary hears obviously he's with this girl
now he's not he's never posted a picture
of his wife not at once interesting not
a once interesting he's the biggest
social media guy out there and he has
never posted a picture of his wife i
don't even know if he had kids i had to
google it mm-hmm and now boom he's
single here's this chick oh and there's
more pictures by the way one at a super
bowl which is having a great time
on vacation would you two say that
that's a trophy wife absolutely
okay tori
i've seen him
i've seen him actually talk really well
about his wife and a lot of interviews
well let's see what happens now all
right so here's here's what here's why
this rubs here's why this rubs women the
wrong way please explain okay so i'm
going to quote rich cooper right now
rich has this one saying it says uh
uh women don't care about men's
struggles they wait at the finish line
and they [ __ ] the winners that's what
basically boils down to now i half agree
with that because when you're 23 years
old and you're looking for you can't
find the winner at 23 years old or maybe
you don't actually want the winner at 23
years old because you're exploring your
options and doing everything that
western culture tells you what to do um
you're looking for a man who has
potential looking for a guy who has a
potential winner because they can't
really because the guys who are winners
are very few and far between and they're
usually a lot older than you because it
takes longer for a man to mature into
the success that he has
over that over the course this is why
you say how women are and men must must
be calm okay so what happens here is you
and this gary is the the epitome of the
worst of women's fears who had to make a
bet on a guy who didn't have jack [ __ ]
and he had a wine company back in the
day
dude i guarantee you
i guarantee you gary's wife took a
chance on him and said this guy's got a
potential he's got ambitious something
about this guy
he's not a winner yet he's not across
the finish line like rich was saying but
i think he could be a winner by the time
he's in his mid-40s
and lo and behold he did become a winner
but and so the worst definitely a winner
so what happens is when women have to
make a bet on that man's potential it's
usually when they're 23 or they're
younger and they're trading their
sexuality their sexual agency and
putting that as the bet on the table
that this horse is going to make it
across the finish line and so what
happens is when that guy actually does
become the winner there's an
investment of resources in this way it's
women's sexual agency my beauty my ut my
my beauty whatever you know my fertility
i give you kids blah blah blah i have
all of this investment in this guy and
now
you're getting rid of that now you have
now you're getting with the hot chick
because you couldn't get with her
when you met me it's disrespectful
i'll say that most guys that know that
you make the bet or whatever if a girl
makes a bet on the guy most guys will
not leave and go for the younger girl
and that's why you're saying most guys
won't do that well not they'd rather be
in an unhappy marriage if they're
unhappy who knows if it's unhappy i'm
just saying if she said here's my my
agency my sexual agency had 22 whatever
the guy will respect it and not do what
he did he's just like that's why i asked
you if you thought she was a trophy wife
because that's the worst fear because
that trophy wife represents the loss of
investment of all that stuff that's
built up although she made 80 million
dollars that's why
this hasn't happened yet and now you
know why divorce is what it is does this
story make you like gary moore or like
him less i don't know that much about
him but i definitely don't like him i
also i can admit that some people get
bored sexually in her marriage maybe
divorces maybe that's why they got
divorced i don't care i don't know i'm
just saying this reflects women's uh
distrust of men sounds like you're like
how about you tori like him more like
him less after this i never really was a
big fan of him but his
no i'm i'm used to seeing this kind of
thing so
not really
well let's just say this at least he's
not jeff bezos because jeff bezos traded
mackenzie bezos for lauren dirty sanchez
49 year old 49 year old lauren dirty
sanchez predatory it's hot for uh
leonardo dicaprio apparently as well so
beautiful well here's my beef with here
gary like she's a career predator woman
she's he's not the first one yes that's
not the first here's my with gary
it it just seems so disrespectful you've
never posted a picture of your wife ever
and now you're you know you're in the
puppy dogs and uh and kittens gary with
your relationships gary and you're
posting this relationship
with this girl i just find it so
disingenuous
i don't know yeah
there's a lot of people that love you
but this is a dirty movie gary is not
used to this he's gary is not used to a
piece of ass like that having anything
to do with like he is his experience
with women over there remember you've
asked me about like jordan peterson yeah
the reason why i have sort of a
lesser opinion of him is because he
doesn't have the experience with women
to speak knowledgeably about it i would
never take advice about women from gary
garyvee sorry
i would never take advice because he
would he would because his experience
with women is limited to his wife from
that from that point on
and then he's probably never had enjoyed
the attentions and affections and
everything of a woman that choice
fair enough
[Music]
you